today we're going to be speaking with Dr
Robert waldinger who's the director of
the Harvard study of adult development
and also co-author of the new book The
Good Life Lessons From the world's
longest scientific study of Happiness
really great to have you on I appreciate
your time well it's great to be here
thanks for having me so one of the
really interesting things about this
study which started in 1938 is many
studies on happiness are of different
groups of people sometimes from
different countries across different
time periods and it can become very
difficult to really compare apples to
apples for for lack of a better term and
one of the interesting things about this
study that now has gone on uh more than
eight decades is it followed the same
individuals and families it's very
extensive asked a ton of questions
hundreds of measurements includes blood
work brain scans I mean you're really
approaching this from a sort of cover
every aspect perspective effective can
you tell us just a little bit about how
this study started the number of people
that were originally part of it in the
number that that are still with us today
sure let's start it as two studies that
didn't know about each other started on
different parts of the Harvard
University campus one was a study begun
at Harvard Health Service the Student
Health Service with sophomores from
Harvard College
and the other was a study of delinquency
a study of delinquent and non-delinquent
boys from Boston's poorest neighborhoods
from the most troubled families
268 Harvard College undergraduates 456
inner city boys and all of them were
studied as a way to understand thriving
how kids moved from childhood into
adulthood on good developmental paths
including the kids who were born with so
many strikes against them you know into
such disadvantaged circumstances
so it was Radical for its time to be
doing these studies of human thriving
and then eventually my predecessor put
the two studies together and started
looking at them as contrasting groups
when we look at the popular literature
on happiness there are all these often
repeated ideas or rules of thumb or
whatever the case may be one of them is
once you make seventy five thousand
dollars a year it's equivalent when you
get beyond that you're not really
anymore sometimes the term is satisfied
with your life sometimes the term happy
is used another one that you often hear
is later in life
having spent more time in the office
rarely correlates to more happiness
whereas having spent more time with
family and having more close
relationships does and you know then
five years go by and there's another
study that comes out and it has a
slightly different different result on
some of those sort of like lowest
hanging fruit things that are often
discussed what has this study determined
well we just determined that the inner
city
group was no less happy than the
privileged Harvard group and that's more
consistent with other studies that say
basically once you get your basic
economic needs met then making more and
more money doesn't do it doesn't
increase your happiness and that seems
to be a pretty robust findings across a
lot of groups of people is there
something to that 75 000 number that you
found no not 75 000 per se and of course
it varies depending on whether you live
in you know the middle of New York City
or you live in rural Iowa right it's
really the question of when when you
have your basic needs met once you've
gotten to that point in terms of income
then more money doesn't do it for you
then you can make millions more and on
average people aren't happier there's
this phrase nobody uh is on their
deathbed wishing they spent more time at
the office right you you you hear that
very often yeah what does the study have
to say about that Dynamic well we ask
people when our first generation folks
were in their 80s we asked them to look
back on their lives and we asked what
are you proudest of and what do you
regret the most and what they regretted
the most particularly the men because
this was the World War II generation
they regretted the most spending too
much time at work and not spending
enough time with the people they cared
about
what they were proudest of was
um was to a person something to do with
their relationships so you know they
didn't say I made a ton of money or I
won all these Awards you know or I was
famous and we had people who were all of
those things
they said I was a good boss I was a good
spouse I was a good friend a good parent
right so when they were looking back on
what was most meaningful it wasn't about
achievement it was about Connections uh
is it true that John F Kennedy was one
of the original participants it is true
and the only reason I can tell you that
is because he was outed by another
journalist about 15 years ago otherwise
we are bound to keep in confidence the
identities of all of the people in our
study so you know in fact the book has
stories of real people woven all through
the book but the the names and The
Superficial details are disguised to
make sure that we protect their privacy
so it sounds like
um money Beyond a certain level not a
big contributor to happiness Fame not a
big contributor to happiness having
spent a lot of time at the office not
not necessarily A contributor
relationships of of different kinds yes
family friendships Etc what else are the
kind of positively correlated
um stories that that you find
taking care of your health matters a lot
you know it's it's like our grandmothers
could have told us that but what we find
and lots of studies find is that you
know getting regular Health Care not
smoking not abusing alcohol and drugs
regular exercise not becoming obese all
of those things make huge differences in
years of life lived and also in years of
healthy life so it really matters a lot
to take care of your health
um the surprising thing for us was the
finding about relationships being so
important because at first we thought
well how could relationships actually
get into your body and and change your
physiology and now for the last 10 years
we've been studying that many other
groups have too and we're understanding
that this is a very powerful robust
connection between
relationships and physical health
what about uh religion because there's
religion can be a tough one where it can
be hard to separate the effect of being
part of a community and the social
aspects versus the religiosity itself
and there's many many studies on this
did you find anything that would be sort
of clear in in the data about religious
participation
well we ask people do you have a
religious practice do you have a
spiritual practice
and there were people who did and there
were people who did not and when we
compared those two groups
neither group was on average happier so
didn't make a difference in your
happiness whether you were spiritual or
religious or not but many of the
religious and spiritual people said that
during times of difficulty their
spiritual practices were helpful to them
so that's more I guess qualitative than
quantitative yeah
when you compare the two groups no one
group isn't happier what about uh travel
because one of the things that's often
written about travel is because when you
travel you're not in your routine
um time seems to go by slower which
often one of the things we read is that
over time you know years go by very very
quickly and part of this seems to be
that there's no cognitive a difference
day to day when you're kind of in your
in your normal day-to-day thing so that
travel is an interesting way and and one
might think there might be some
correlation to happiness as well there
is there anything
we did not study that specifically but
what you're saying makes a lot of sense
and and what we do find is that more
cognitive stimulation Keeps Us sharper
over time and that includes being
connected with other people so one of
the the effects we think of
relationships on keeping our brains
healthy yeah is that it stimulates us
people are always unpredictable they're
moving targets what what you're gonna
say to me next is something I don't know
right and that keeps my brain clicking
on all cylinders that's a good thing for
the brain and I think what you're
pointing out is that travel can do the
same thing that's why time seems to go
more slowly during travel because we're
like on alert like what am I gonna see
now how do I find my way here it's it's
all of those challenges that we think
Keeps Us healthy cognitively as we get
older one of the things that is it's not
unique to the United States but it's
certainly been written about a lot in
the United States is the trend that
people move relatively frequently in
modern American society much more
commonly than in other parts of the
world don't live near their families nor
where they grew up I was recently
reading Jared Diamond's book about
traditional societies and he said well a
big difference there aside from all
sorts of other differences is that in
more traditional societies people tend
to live near where they grew up and near
their family most of their lives in the
United States it's increasingly uncommon
was there something garnered from the
study related to that about those who
kind of stay what we might call close to
home versus those that don't
what we found was a difference in the
inner city group from the Harvard group
and that made a whole lot of sense
because the Harvard group was gathered
from all over the country Harvard
College brings in undergrads from
everywhere in the U.S and sometimes
abroad
unlike the inner city group where they
were
chosen because they lived in Boston
their families lived in Boston and what
we found then in the next generation was
that of course more of the inner city
group lived in this area stayed near
their families now what we have not done
is an analysis that compares are those
second generation people in the Inner
City Group happier than the more widely
dispersed Harvard people I expect that
research exists we just haven't done it
interesting in terms of the
relationships lots of studies on
friendship that look at number of
friends but also quality of relationship
and what you see frequently repeated in
popular Publications is it's not about
having many friends as one ages it's
about having a few uh very strong or
rewarding relationships that really
seems to correlate not only with
happiness but sometimes even like a
health claim will be made
um what what about that distinction
well what we find is that you know as
with so many things when you follow
thousands of lives one size never fits
all so we're all on a spectrum
temperamentally from introversion
shyness to extroversion and most of us
are somewhere in the middle but there
are extremes and what we find is that
shy people
find lots of people around them to be
stressful so actually having a lot of
connections in your life could be more
stressful if you're temperamentally
introverted on the other hand
extroverted people get their energy from
people so they may need a lot of people
so what we find is that it's a highly
individual matter and that each of us
can really discern for ourselves what's
the amount of connection that works for
me in my life and how can I work to have
the amount that feels right to me that's
interesting I mean holding all else
equal do you know whether introverts or
extroverts seem to be happier
I don't know that I do know that for
example Susan Kane some of her work that
there are people who work on this and I
don't believe people have found that
introverts or extroverts are happier
than the opposite extreme at all
um I think one of the complicating
factors is that our culture
um
glorifies extraversion yeah no being a
party animal right you know that's like
an iconic character in films and
literature on social media right and so
that bias toward extroversion can make
introverted people feel like there may
be something wrong with them what we
know is there isn't anything wrong with
them at all it's perfectly normal
adaptive some of the most wonderful most
brilliant most talented people are shy
not a problem
uh the book is called the good life
lessons from the world's longest
scientific study of Happiness we've been
speaking with the books co-author Dr
Robert waldinger really appreciate your
time and insights today
thank you for having me